tf1 20 heures avec roger gicquel terreur
à paris cinq morts 40 blessés trois
immeubles détruits par une série
d'explosions de gaz les points chauds
des législatives duel serré à reims où
le pcv gagné les municipales
les syndicats italiens prêt à cautionner
une politique d'austérité en quête de
françois go sur ce virage sans précédent
demain france irlande avec un nouveau
dans le quinze de france louis bilbao
bonsoir oui tout un quartier du 16e
arrondissement de paris est devenue zone
interdite de cet après midi l'ennemi
c'était le gaz de ville à 15h30 première
explosion dans un immeuble
et comme à evreux l'autre jour les gens
se sont précipités pour voir et une
demi-heure après seconde explosion là où
étaient les badauds et l'accident
devenait tragédie tout le quartier entre
la rue raynouard et la venue de lamballe
était menacé on ne pouvait plus arrêter
le gaz on devait évacuer les l'école
saint-jean-de-passy à 16h30 troisième
explosion dans un immeuble et il y à une
heure le gaz continuaient d'exploser
quatre fois consécutives dans les égouts
bilan de ces explosions en série 5 morts
au moins mais peut-être le double 40
blessés c'était comme si le quartier
avait été bombardée c'était l'affolement
les reporter sur place par les mêmes
d'apocalypse quand il vivait la
situation les pompiers ne pouvaient pas
accéder aux immeubles
une forte odeur de gaz continuaient à se
répandre et ont demandé aux riverains
d'évacuer leurs appartements
une information contre x a été ouverte
pour rechercher les responsabilités de
ces explosions le point maintenant sur
place avec vous jean pire à bout on est
roger gicquel ici nous sommes au coeur
même de l'endroit où ont eu lieu les
sept explosions et il ya toujours des
risques d'explosion
trois explosions au même eu lieu il y à
quelques minutes
en fait le gaz a été coupé un vers 18h30
immeuble par immeuble par les pompiers
et les employés du gaz de france qui ont
creusé des tranchées mais il ya toujours
des nappes de gaz dans les canalisations
et dans les sous sols je suis ici avec
le colonel coupet qui s'occupe justement
ici des secours en pompier au collège ce
que vous pensez qu'il
des risques d'explosion dans les heures
qui viennent non je pense que maintenant
les choses sont terminées le gaz de
france est enfin terminée de vider les
canalisations
nous non nous d'éteindre les foyers
d'incendié résiduelles je pense qu'il
n'y a plus de problème du côté les
explosions par contre les bâtiments sont
ébranlait il est évident qu'on a des
risques d'effondrement justement vos
hommes sont entrés en ce moment d'être
dans un immeuble est ce que vous pensez
que malheureusement il pourrait avoir
d'autres victimes dans des immeubles et
bien c'est encore très possible puisque
à l'arrivée nous avons découvert un mort
et deux blessés dans le premier après la
première explosion
nous avons dû nous retirer quand un
suite aux autres explosions et le fait
que le gaz depa groupe et il est donc
très possible qui est sous les
éboulements je ne le souhaite pas mais
qui est très sous les éboulements des
victimes
est ce que l'idée maintenant des causes
de ces explosions et de ces fuites de
gaz on tenait à aucune demande de mon
côté
les explosions et les incendies qui ont
suivi sont dus au gaz et tout ce que je
peux vous dire une vingtaine d'immeubles
ont été évacués la guerre dans tout le
quartier c'est un millier ce sont un
millier de locataires pardon qui ont été
hébergés ce soir par la mairie de paris
et les pompiers mon colonel demande à ce
que les badauds et les personnes ne
viennent surtout pas dans ce quartier
bien évidemment la police est d'ailleurs
entoure le coin et empêche des ballots
d'approché parce qu'il ya toujours des
risques d'éboulement voilà le point
roger gicquel acheteurs si évidemment
s'il y avait quoi que ce soit dans le
journal on interviendrait ce moment là
merci jean pierre un mouvement leurs
règles vous ravir pietri il faudrait
revenir à l'origine de ces explosions la
première
eh bien écoutez nous allons revivre cet
après-midi intensément sur les images
les plus saisissantes tournées par nos
équipes de reportage filmé et h f
alors la première explosion donc dont
l'origine reste indéterminée
elle se produite au 1 de la rue colonel
bonnet il est 15h30
elle est très violente est immédiatement
allé suivi d'un violent incendie dans
les sept étages de l'immeuble un
kilomètre à la ronde les vitres des
immeubles ont été pulvérisés des
voitures propulsées sur les trottoirs
des plaques de fonte qui en tueur
entoure les arbres catapulté à plusieurs
centaines de mètres de là il y a les
cris des blessés les appels au secours
au balcon et aux fenêtres et aussitôt
vous l'avez vu des secours qui arrivent
mais aussi les badauds et les curieux et
c'est la deuxième explosion à 50 mètres
à peine de la première dans les sous sol
de l'immeuble situé au 60 rue raynouard
à 50 mètres de la donne trois personnes
sont tuées par des projectiles le feu
embrase aussi une partie de l'immeuble
tout le quartier est alors sévèrement
bloqué pompiers et spécialistes du gaz
de france commence une exploration
systématique lente et difficile des sous
sols de tous les immeubles mais aussi
des étages on dégage les morts et les
blessés
et l'on essaie de maîtriser les nappes
de gaz une partie de ce gaz en effet
s'est accumulée en poche dans les
profondeurs mais une autre partie allégé
semble-t-il par la chaleur s'est
dispersée et flambe çà et là en torchère
se propageant voisinage par les
canalisations et c'est vers 16h15 la
troisième explosion
28 rue de lamballe elle fait d'autres
dégâts et d'autres blessés c'est un
paysage de bombardements vous le disiez
tout à l'heure les habitants du quartier
et de l'école saint-jean-de-passy sont
évacués et réinstaller dans des centres
d'hébergement
les blessés sont transportés à l'hôpital
ambroise paré bilan à 7 heures 5 morts
et 40 blessés mais un bilan très
provisoire répétons le tandis que les
pompiers et les techniciens purge les
canalisations du réseau du quartier pour
ceux qui ont vécu cet après midi c'est
une véritable scène de guerre qui est
décrite par exemple par ce témoin qui a
rencontré claude bertrand c'est
l'explosion à bord on était dedans dans
la maison qu'est ce qui s'est passé je
ne sais pas comment mais vu qu'on vous
dis-je et à quel numéro exprime la venue
de lamballe qu'est ce qui s'est passé
une première explosion avenue du colonel
bonnet fort très fort et la seconde est
cloué explosion des cas on verra la
maison gardant l'essence dans la maison
que faisiez-vous oui tu vous nous étions
septièmes et à remonter tranquillement
installés aux salomon avec des amis et
tout à coup de lettres ont éclaté à
grosse fumée le feu les tâches dont ce
aussi bien la première explosion
on a senti une odeur de gaz alors
qu'est-ce que vous avez pas que les
confins sont américaines à l'intérieur
l'immeuble a été évacuée maintenant oui
avait en tout cas les autres je peux pas
vous dire et après il ya eu une deuxième
explosion deuxième explosion chez nous
alors dans le lit marin troisième tout à
l'heure
hier notre descente l échelle on était
en train de vous sauver de l'appartement
et on a trouvé un petit groupe de gens
j'ai demandé s'il y avait du monde à
l'intérieur personne ne savait avec
quelques personnes il est rentré on a
commencé à essayer de de déblayer les
pompistes egypte est une lutte après on
avait encore un petit peu aider à
déblayer parce qu'ils n'étaient pas très
nombreux au début et peut-être depuis
trois minutes qu'on était là tu le
deuxième immeuble qui est en face à
sauter a pris feu immédiatement enfin au
niveau du rez-de-chaussée ça a pris feu
immédiatement
il y avait des gens dans les étages qui
ont ouvert les fenêtres pour les
pompiers leur ont crié de refermer de
fermer les portes et c'est beaucoup de
dégâts beaucoup de dégâts tout était
tout était le premier immeuble tout
effet ce aux frais jusqu'au à l'aplomb
du deuxième étage et un peu plus tard
encore il y à peine une heure une heure
et demie il y a trois nouvelles
explosions dans les sous sols dans les
égouts de la rue singer qui est un
proche de là quatre explosions
mais la première explosion n'a pas
d'origine précise déclare de gaz de
france les canalisations du quartier et
le derner belle était neuf et souvent
vérifié alors il reste qu'il a été très
difficile de trouver les fuites de gaz
de les déterminer
comme l'a précisé d'ailleurs un porte
parole du gaz de france à alain rodier
et bien en ce qui concerne la ville de
paris il y à un système d'alarmé
c'est à dire un certain nombre de
camionnettes qui dispose la radio et ils
sont prévenus par un centre qui
immédiatement les dépêches
à l'endroit où il ya eu un problème il
est extrêmement difficile de faire mieux
un secteur pour la bonne raison que les
réseaux de gaz sont entièrement mag et
c'est à dire qu'elles sont absolument
comme un filet et vous ne pouvez pas
couper une semaine canalisations
justement c'est fait pour des raisons de
sécurité pour l'ensemble du quartier
pour que s'il ya une égalisation qui est
coupé accidentellement les gens soient
qu elle fournit en gaz dans les autres
parties du quartier donc de la façon de
procéder consiste à rechercher la fuite
et a coupé uniquement la partie de
réseaux qui est suspecte
alors comment procédez-vous sur le
terrain alors sur le terrain on fait des
sondages avec des appareils spéciaux qui
montrent s'il ya du gaz aussi y en a pas
et à partir de ces renseignements on
peut localiser une fuite ça prend plus
ou moins de temps il ya partiront la
fuite est localisée naturellement en
ouvre la canalisation a cepandant là et
on la coupe ou debout et généralement
pas avec des ballons c'est à dire qu'on
fait des trous dans la conduite de part
et d'autre on met des petits ballons
cambon pour facile faire étanchéité donc
c'est tout de même une question de temps
vous ne pouvez pas il n'y a pas
d'intervention l'a tellement immédiate
en appuyant sur des boutons mans on
rentrait avec la cité où vous déclenchez
un disjoncteur vous arrêtez tout là
c'est pas possible en matière de gaz là
par exemple en ce moment les pompiers
non je crois que l'heure on n'a pas pu
encore couper les canalisations
on peut couper les alimentations
d'immeubles parce qu'il y à des robinets
spéciaux mais sur le réseau nous n'avons
pas de vannes
en temps normal quelle est l'étendue de
son réseau à paris plusieurs centaines
de kilomètres voilà et puis il faut bien
versé ce témoignage au dossier
maintenant ce soir ça témoignages qui
était entendue sur ce chez un confrère à
rtl précisément c'est un gardien
d'immeuble un gardien non pas d'un des
immeubles qui a sauté mais d'un immeuble
voisin qui dit à partir de 3 heures du
matin cette nuit j'ai détecté une odeur
de gaz dans les parkings
alors j'ai appelé l'edf j'ai eu du mal à
obtenir udf et vers 8h du matin même
vers 9 heures du matin on est venu sur
place et la légende du gaz de france
n'ont rien détecté
voilà si cette information se vérifie
c'est tout de même assez grave et je
vous le dis c'est un témoignage ce n'est
qu'un témoignage mais il est important
si toutefois vous aviez l'intention de
vous présenter aux élections
législatives et que vous ne soyez pas
encore inscrit sachez tout de même que
vous avez encore le temps de le faire il
vous reste 48 heures clôture des
inscriptions dimanche à minuit ensuite
début de la campagne électorale
officielle c'est-à-dire qu'on pourra
placer des affiches officielles sur les
panneaux officiels et que vous recevrez
les tracts officielle des candidats leur
profession de foi
et même si l'on vous dit saturé de
politique même si vous croyez tout
savoir sur l'enjeu de ces élections sur
la compétence et la personnalité des
candidats
cette campagne officielle précédé de
longs mois de polémique électorale
devrait pouvoir vous éclairer éclairer
votre lanterne et faciliter votre choix
à son heure comme le veut la loi le
service public de la radio télévision
viendra alimenter votre réflexion
c'est ainsi que débute le journal des
législatives d'aujourd'hui avec vous
patrice duhamel
oui il peut paraître surprenant de
parler d'ouverture de la campagne alors
que depuis plus d'un an maintenant le
pays vit au rythme et dans la tempe des
élections législatives
certains regrettent cette omniprésence
de la politique d'autres s'en félicite
mais c'est ainsi et c'est bien le débat
démocratique et candidats et les partis
vont donc en effet engagé la dernière
ligne droite lundi prochain et c'est une
semaine plus tard le lundi 27 février
que s'ouvrira la campagne électorale à
la télévision et à la radio
chaque soir sauf le samedi et le
dimanche et simultanément sur les trois
chaînes de télévision et radio france
les parties
tic et notamment leur grande vedette
vous les voyez ici ce qui occupe la
scène politique depuis de longs mois
présenteront donc leurs arguments et
leurs propositions
les principaux partis ceux qui disposent
de groupes parlementaires dans
l'assemblée nationale actuelle auront
180 minutes au total avant le 12 mars
avant le premier tour 90 minutes pour la
majorité 90 minutes pour l'opposition
entre les deux tours ce sera 45 minutes
pour la majorité 45 minutes pour
l'opposition
les autres formations politiques celles
qui présentent au moins 75 candidats
disposeront chacune de sept minutes
avant le premier tour et de cinq minutes
entre le 12 et le 19 mars à partir du 27
février donc du lundi au vendredi et à
20h30 tout de suite après le journal
vous pourrez suivre cette campagne
officielle elle durera 25 à 35 minutes
chaque soir avant le 12 mars un peu plus
longtemps
entre les deux tours il y aura cependant
deux exceptions le 1er et le 8 mars en
raison de l'actualité sportive
ce sera en effet bastia iéna en coupe
d'europe le 1er mars et france portugal
le 8 mars toujours un football bien sûr
au total un programme très chargé donc à
la mesure sans doute de l'enjeu
électoral de mars à 23 jours du 12 mars
voyons maintenant l'essentiel des
déclarations de la journée avec
christian de dadelsen le premier
ministre refuse un débat télévisé avec
georges marche il ne pourrait se
concevoir écrit-il dans une lettre
adressée aux leaders communistes que si
vous vous présentiez en tant que chef de
l'opposition georges marchais répond à
raymond barre dans l'humanité vous avez
déjà débattu avec françois mitterrand un
nouveau refus signifierait que vous vous
attribuiez le droit de désigner vous
même le chef de l'opposition michel
debré à france inter a souligné que le
rpr n'avait pas à céder à monsieur
raymond barre une partie de son temps de
parole à la télévision et à la radio
pendant la campagne électorale jean
pierre soisson avait demandé hier aux
formations de la majorité de le faire
dans le débat politique c'est toujours
la crise de la gauche qui domine georges
séguy critique le financement du
programme socialiste pour lui adopter ce
projet reviendrait à renoncer à des
revendications essentielles telles que
la semaine de 40 heures ou la retraite à
55 ans pour les femmes
sondage valeurs actuelles sofres les
français refusent au parti communiste
les grands ministères qu'il
revendiquerait selon monsieur
poniatowski dans un éventuel
gouvernement de gauche
il ne lui accorde que les affaires
sociales débat à tf1 jean pierre
chevènement qualifie de mesures
répressives le refus opposé par
plusieurs tribunaux administratifs aux
candidatures de jeunes soldats réponse
de yvon bourges ministre de la défense
les candidatures de militaires ne sont
pas du ressort de l'armée mais des
tribunaux et pour être candidat il faut
avoir satisfait à ses obligations
militaires c'est la loi vote des
français de l'étranger 2000 inscriptions
rejeté 2000 en suspens sur vingt-deux
mille contester ces indications fournies
par le ministre des affaires étrangères
interviennent au lendemain de la
question écrite que françois mitterrand
adressée au premier ministre
et puis je vous propose ce soir une
nouvelle circonscription test une
circonscription particulièrement
intéressantes sur plan politique la
première de la marne reims dont la
mairie a été enlevé à la majorité à la
majorité l'an dernier par un communiste
claude lamblin reportage patrick de
carolis à reims depuis que les dernières
élections municipales ont donné à reims
1 ère communiste où les états majors
politiques ont les yeux fixés sur sa
1ère circonscription le député sortant
roger crespin rpr ancien suppléant de
jean taittinger a été écarté de la
compétition
c'est jacques kosciusko morizet qui
portera les couleurs du parti de jacques
chirac
à 64 ans il a une longue expérience de
la vie administrative et diplomatique
directeur de cabinet de vincent auriol
maire de saint nom la bretèche puis
ambassadeur de france aux états unis il
espère devenir l'ambassadeur de reims et
de la champagne auprès de la france mais
pour cela il faut qu'ils devancent au
premier tour jean louis schneiter cds il
est le candidat de l'union pour la
démocratie française
il a 45 ans et comme le veut la
tradition dans sa famille les négociants
ben ils bénéficient en outre de l'image
de marque de son père pierre schneiter
ancien ministre ancien président de
l'assemblée nationale et ancien maire de
reims jean louis schneiter et jacques
kosciusko morizet espère chacun sans
l'avouer vraiment battre un record celui
de jean taittinger qui il y a cinq ans
avait obtenu au deuxième tour 57,3 % des
suffrages exprimés
à gauche ils sont 2 également l'actuel
maire de reims le communiste claude
lamblin 40 ans instituteur il n'a connu
jusqu'à près
sans aucun échec électoral mais voilà il
a eu quelques problèmes aux cintres en
français municipal avec les 18 élus
socialistes qui ont refusé de voter le
budget supplémentaire leur chef de file
c'est georges cole et c'est lui qui se
présente pour le parti socialiste dans
la même circonscription
il a 47 ans enseignant puis doyenne la
faculté de lettres de reims et
conseiller général
son résultat aura valeur de test il
montrera comment été ressentie à la base
la désunion pc ps à ces quatre
prétendants viennent se greffer pour
l'instant un écologiste et un candidat
de l'action républicaine indépendante et
libéral en fait pour bien comprendre la
situation rémoise il faut considérer
deux choses la première c'est que les
résultats des élections municipales ont
atteint la longue stabilité politique de
la région
cela inquiète la majorité mais cela
encourage en même temps l'opposition
deuxièmement c'est que depuis ces
élections municipales prince est devenu
en quelque sorte le symbole de la
désunion de la gauche alors cela
préoccupe l'opposition mais cela rassure
la majorité
le virage l'as volts en italien c'est le
mot qui s'étalait ces jours ci à la une
de tous les journaux italiens
ça voulait dire virage des syndicats qui
représentent 9 millions d'adhérents
autant dire qu'ils sont plus puissants
ces syndicats que les nôtres le taux de
syndicalisation en italie est plus fort
à la cgt française par exemple il ya 2
millions 300 mille adhérents à la cgt
italienne 4 millions 300 mille
or les trois syndicats italiens viennent
d'adopter ensemble c'est un acte
unitaire un programme approuvé par la
base semble-t-il un programme qui
acceptent une certaine austérité pour
sortir le pays de la crise
avec priorité à la lutte contre le
chômage bien un million six cent mille
chômeurs en italie et c'est pour cette
raison que toutes les centrales
syndicales italiennes se déclare prête à
accepter de sérieux sacrifices non sans
contrepartie puisque les syndicats
veulent en échange davantage de pouvoir
au sein des entreprises
luciano lama le secrétaire général de la
cgl a admis qu'il fallait revenir sur
certains avantages acquis et le patronat
aussitôt s'est réjoui de cette
autocritique
en quoi consiste ce virage des syndicats
italiens qui n'ont plus de lien formel
avec les partis politiques il faut le
souligner françois go est allé enquêter
sur place
nous proposons travailleurs italiens une
politique de sacrifices et pas de petits
sacrifices des sacrifices importants et
revendications salariales des ouvriers
qui ont un emploi doivent passer au
deuxième plan
on ne peut pas obliger les entreprises à
conserver un effectif de travailleurs
sans commune mesure avec leurs capacités
productives
ce n'est pas un dirigeant patronal qui a
prononcé ces mots c'est luciano lama le
secrétaire général de la cgl la cgt
italienne oui avec l'automne chaud 1969
les syndicats ont apporté au travail en
italien le statut social le plus avancé
d'europe aujourd'hui pour sortir le pays
de la crise
il accepte l'austérité mais sous
conditions nous n'acceptons pas nous la
revendiquons parce que nous pensons que
dans le contexte économique italienne
une solution à la crise du pays à la
crise économique sociale mais nous
l'avons dit aussi morale du pays est
impossible sans changer profondément les
structures industrielles les structures
productives et par conséquent même
l'organisation du pouvoir
les critères de la planification
économique
cela n'est pas possible sans une
politique d'austérité c'est à dire sans
introduire des critères de contrôle
effectif dans la dynamique des
consommations en privilégiant les
consommations des couches les plus
défavorisées et en privilégiant les
consommations collective par rapport aux
consommations individuelles
un exemple parmi d'autres l'emploi la
mobilité de la main d'oeuvre quand nous
disons que dans certaines branches dans
certaines usines qui sont voués à là au
déclin il faut accepter la mobilité du
travail mais la négocier mais la
contrôler et obtenir par conséquent le
passage de l'emploi à un autre et non
pas d'un emploi au chômage
quand nous disons cela nous savons de
heurtée à une résistance instinctive de
groupes de travailleurs qui pensent
qu'il faut de toute façon défendant le
travail là où il est là où ils se
trouvent indépendant dans les conditions
économiques langage nouveau c'est vrai
toutefois pas de chèque en blanc
en échange de sacrifices librement
consentie et aussi avec leur poids
politique
les syndicats l'italien réclame
aujourd'hui un véritable projet de
société pour l'italie voilà le sens de
ce virage de cette vuelta solution début
de solution dans l'énigme du club
méditerranée de corfou je pense que vous
en souvenez c'est là qu'avait eu lieu
l'un des hold-up de l'été dernier et
trois gangsters s'étaient emparés de
l'argent des estivants c'était le 7
juillet 1977 il s'était enfui ces
gangsters par la mer avec 120 millions
de centimes et 700 passeport un moniteur
de ski nautique jean maurice patching
bino bob patching bono pardon âgé de 30
ans qui avait tenté de s'opposer à leur
fuite avait été tué d'une balle dans les
reins par l'un des gangsters une enquête
internationale avait été aussitôt
déclenchée en grèce en yougoslavie en
italie dans le midi et le nord de la
france sept mois d'enquêté acharnée avec
pierre la réussite des policiers
l'arrestation de deux des trois
gangsters aux baléares
le troisième est toujours en fuite ce
sont comme robert werner va vous le dire
des photos de vacances des années
précédentes qui ont permis l'arrestation
des gangsters
c'est une journée radieuse ce 16 juillet
1977 et trois gangsters qui ont mis
leurs méfaits au point lors d'un autre
séjour à corfou ont fracassé ce joli
décor de vacances il se précipite dans
le local où se trouve un million deux
cent mille francs l'argent des
vacanciers qui viennent d'arriver et il
fuit vers la mer un organisateur du club
rugby man et courageux les poursuites de
gangsters sont déjà de l'autre côté de
la clôture du camp des vacances mais le
troisième risque de ne pas passer et
l'organisateur va arriver il le placo
jambes on tire sur lui et on le tue les
malfaiteurs foncent vers le yacht qui
les attend d'autres membres du club leur
cours après l'appui de leur voiture trop
tard les gangsters embarquant
catastrophe
eh bien on va les suivre en hors bord
tandis que les bandits qui continue à
tirer mais celui ci va tomber en panne
d'essence
la première manche est gagnée pour les
bandits qui viennent de tuer un homme de
30 ans il accoste en italie en compagnie
du propriétaire du yacht
celui ci dira plus tard je n'ai pas
parlé parce que
j'avais peur mais on l'a inculpé pour
complicité l'enquète des policiers m et
blanc et pellegrini qui remporteront la
deuxième manche commence on fouille
toute l'île de corfou
on apprend que dans un hôtel luxueux
trois français de 35 ans environ ont
séjourné peu avant le hold up il avait
des compagnes qui ignoraient leur vraie
identité
on retrouve ces jeunes femmes est l'une
d'elles se souvient avoir tourné un
petit film d'amateur mais on y voit
surtout les gangsters de dos sauf sur un
plan il va tout déclencher
l'homme ses rues quoi qui est soupçonné
d'être le meurtrier on diffuse sa photo
dans le nord de la france les policiers
le connaissent il est sorti de prison 60
gaz on découvre qu'il a effectivement
séjourné à corfou avec ses deux
complices qu'il a connus en prison à
liancourt
ce sont des braqueurs il s'appelle
angèle et le compte les enquêteurs sont
parfois sur les traces des trois hommes
mais il leur échappe toujours au dernier
moment or une femme de rejoindre l'un
d'eux cet ange llc où il est à majorque
dans les baléares
elle compte se marier avec lui le 15
février dernier les policiers français a
brisé dans une villa que les arrêter
dans de très bonnes conditions
dangereuses morue quoi n'était pas là je
suppose qu'ils se séparent et
mentalement
ses deux amis et recoins est le plus
dangereux et au koala est
malheureusement le plus dangereux
enfin les identifier nous ne désespérons
pas à l'arrêter dans les jours qui
viennent on retrouve deux cent cinquante
mille francs seulement sur un million
deux cent mille reste à extrader ces
malfaiteurs professionnels mais cela
n'est jamais facile
oui ils ont été arrêtés aux baléares je
vous le rappelle
en bref avec vous éric gilbert réseau de
nouvelles de ce journal les 15 membres
la fédération d'éducation nationale qui
siégeait au conseil supérieur de
l'éducation viennent de démissionner de
cette instance motif le syndicat d'andré
henry reproche à au ministre rené haby
d'avoir bousculé et modifier le
calendrier des séances du conseil
supérieur de l'éducation
cela pour se dépêcher de faire appliquer
une série de mesures en faveur de
l'enseignement privé avant les
législatives du fond de la cellule où il
purge une peine d'un an de prison pour
son rôle dans le scandale du watergate
l'ancien conseiller de richard nixon
global de man vient d'écrire un livre de
mémoires plutôt explosif haldeman
affirme tout bonnement qu'en 1970 les
russes avaient proposé aux américains de
détruire la chine à coups de bombes
atomiques
celui que l'on appelait le chien de
garde de nixon prétend même que les
soviétiques voulaient déversé 1800
missiles nucléaires sur le territoire
chinois
ces révélations ont déjà provoqué les
démentis catégoriques de kissinger
chargé à l'époque de la politique
étrangère américaine et aussi de l'âge
ans tu as il n'empêche que certains
observateurs politiques américains ne
sont pas sûrs qu'il s'agisse vraiment
d'un bluff intégral simplement destiné à
faire vendre le livre dalle demain
bavure policière près de paris un jeune
professeur pris par erreur pour un
gangster par une patrouille de police à
ablon dans le val de marne porte plainte
les policiers dit il mon mal traités de
plus ils ont tiré dans ma voiture et
refusent de rembourser les dégâts causés
à la carrosserie
alors qu'ils ont quand même failli me
tuer bien entendu les gs la police des
polices a été saisie de cette affaire
décidément il se passe des choses
deviennent inquiétantes dans certaines
maisons de retraite tandis que les
policiers belle se demande toujours si
soeur gottfried à la religieuse accusé
d'avoir tué trois vieillards à l'hospice
de gand n'a pas fait d'autres victimes
et bien leurs collègues français a eu
enquête dans une maison de repos de la
banlieue marseillaise il y aurait eu
plusieurs décès suspect dans cet
établissement appelé le centre vers clos
et la directrice est même accusé d'autre
part d'avoir escroqué plusieurs
pensionnaires
neuf mineurs sont encore bloqués au fond
du puits de tata banias hongrie le coup
de grisou qui a ravagé hier soir cette
mine de charbon située au nord de
budapest a déjà fait 17 morts et
plusieurs dizaines de blessés
les opérations de sauvetage vont
continuer pendant plusieurs jours un
industriel italien été libéré
aujourd'hui contre rançon les gangsters
qui l'avait kidnappée l'ont gardé deux
mois à ce propos on peut remarquer que
lundi cela fera tout juste un mois que
le baron empain été enlevée à paris et
que pour l'instant on n'a toujours
aucune information sur le déroulement
des négociations entre la famille et les
ravisseurs
un nouveau trésor culturel découvert par
hasard à sienne en italie un peintre qui
resterait une des églises de la ville a
mis à jour une série de fresques du 15e
siècle entre autres une naissance de la
vierge une annonciation et une adoration
d'héberger ses oeuvres sont attribués à
l'un des maîtres de la reconnaît de la
renaissance italienne francesco di
giorgio martini un homme au génie
multiples puisqu'il était à la fois
peintre sculpteur architecte et aussi
ingénieur militaire ce qui est plus
étonnant les parisiens eux ont eu la
primeur de la donation pierre lévy la
fabuleuse collection donné à l'étape par
l'industriel troyan est en effet exposé
depuis ce matin au musée de l'orangerie
ses toiles l'étoile pour la plupart des
oeuvres de peintres fauves resteront là
jusqu'à ce que soient prêts le musée qui
leur est destiné à l'évêché de 3 à
quelques centaines de mètres d'ailleurs
du domicile du donateur
changement de programme enfin pour les
turfistes la réunion d'auteuil étant
annulait le tiercé de dimanche se
disputera à vincennes dans le prix de la
mayenne
il s'agit bien sûr d'une course de trop
pour le moment 18 chevaux sont engagés
le temps bien si le temps est resté
froid aujourd'hui au nord de la seine
ailleurs ça bien été l'heureux doux avec
des températures entre - 2 dans le
nord-est et +15 en corse
dans l'est la neige et le verglas ont
provoqué de nombreux accidents au sud de
toulouse une vingtaine de camions se
sont mis en travers de la route et ont
bloqué la circulation en moselle des
sangliers affamés se sont approchés d'un
village et habitants du les chasser et
puis en montagne à nouveau les
avalanches le tunnel du mont blanc a dû
être fermé à cause de cela sur le
versant italien en suisse deux skieurs
ont été tuées et les dangers
d'avalanches perd 6 à tous le thé à
toutes les altitudes
dans les alpes du nord demain toujours
du mauvais temps brumeux le matin très
nuageux avec des pluies intermittentes
et de la neige en montagne au dessus de
1800 mètres et des côtes nord de la
bretagne au nord du jura le temps
restera froid et couverts
accompagné de pluie de neige et de
verglas et dimanche j'ai bien peur que
le temps soit aussi médiocre que le
temps de demain décidément en rugby le
tournoi des six nations se joue à six
est l'adversaire le plus dur cette année
c'est la neige c'est la boue ce sont les
terrains détrempés les bataille d'avants
deviennent des assauts de courage
physique individuelle qui sont tout à
fait prenant quand on regarde entre les
lignes du téléviseur les ballons qui
glissent les avants qui dérape sous nous
font vraiment participer à ce match
parce qu'on dit qu'on serait on se dit
qu'on serait 1000 fois plus maladroit
que les joueurs à leur place
eh bien demain la france affrontera
l'irlande c'est le troisième match
elle a gagné les deux précédents contre
l'angleterre et décosse ça a été dur
et s'il n'y a aucune chute de neige sur
le parc des princes d'ici demain la
rencontre devrait devrait se dérouler
dans d'assez bonnes conditions les
pompiers de paris sont venus déblayer la
neige ce matin
la pelouse est grasse mais praticable
mais c'est tout de même dans la neige
que le quinze de france s'est entraînée
à reuil hier et aujourd'hui une équipe à
laquelle on n'a pas porté de gants
changement sauf au poste de trois quart
aile jean françois gourdon a cédé la
place à louis bilbao
un petit nouveau si j'ose dire voilà
vous savez presque tout je dois rendre
l'antenne maintenant bonne soirée à tous
au nom de toute l'équipe de tf1
actualité prochain journal jean pierre
pernaut vers 23h20 merci